you
you
good morning members members of the
public
you're very welcome here the smaller I'd
like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the Internet and will be capable of
repeated filling the hold of the meeting
will be filmed except with where there
are confidential or exempt items this is
rather long members and members of the
public LaHood got a read at all through
any member of the public who attends a
meetin and objects to being filmed
should have a file use the committee
Clark
is anybody here objects no if you make a
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed by entering
this room you are also consenting to
being filmed by the council and the
possibility use of those images and
sound recordings for webcasting and/or
for training purposes the council
members the public and press may record
film photograph or broadcast this meet
and when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded in accordance with the
council's plan and charter members of
the public are not permitted to
communicate whether thoroughly or in
writing with members of the committee
during the course of the meeting
including any adjournments if a member
of the committee is approached by a
member of the public then they must
immediately draw it to my attention and
also to the attention of the legal
adviser present if a member of the
public attempts to communicate with a
member of the committee then they may be
asked to leave the meeting finally can
members and officers please ensure that
you press the microphone for speaking
and turn off when you have finished
I'll now hand over to rob to read as the
health and safety Thank You chair we'll
try and get this organized a little bit
better the next time so just for
reference the toilets situated outside
the meeting room opposite the stairs
cold water is available in the breakout
area outside the meeting room and if the
fire alarm should sound please leave via
the exit signs and meet on if switch
Town Football Club training pitch and do
not re-enter the building until you were
told it is safe to do so and assignment
thank you Jeff so make sure your phones
are turned off members thank you they
will return to the agenda first items
substitutes and apologies Chancellor
John Osbourne Thank You mr. chairman
councillor Journal's born subbing for
councillor suit Ayres thank you very
much
councillor Davis Council today was
substituted for councillor Hinton thank
you other than that I think we're all
present right I'm just going to take
this opportunity to welcome the new
members of the planning committee your
names will come up if you speak during
the course of the meeting but I think
just as a quick exercise I'm going to
ask the members just to announce their
names so that you'll get used to using
the microphones in front of you
we'll start with don't cancel Adair
Davis yep councillor Davis Dave Busby
counselor Alison Owen leave Jameson
Melanie Barrett exact moment count sir
Adrian Osborn counselor John Osborn
thank you I'm now down to ask top tailor
just to enjoy Ian's Despres solicitor
and legal advisors this committee Steven
Blum vice chair I'm Steven Stroud I'm
the counsel strategic projects manager
and I'm supporting the chair and vice
chair last Robert Carmichael governor's
support officer right okay and the other
officers along the back here as they
percent papers to us they will introduce
themselves to us okay so that you all
know who they all are and my name speed
to be I'm chairman at the Planning
Committee and I know my colleague office
of planning and he's got this fancy
title but I wish I heard to the one
sitting here is the chief planning
officer because he's conducting that
part of the meeting this morning so
you've got that title it's simpler and
easier and people understand it right
we'll move on to declarations of
interest do I have any pencil of Barrett
yes
can I declare the canary interest in the
first and only application today my
niece my marriage is an employee of the
school chairman the indeed this is a
non-pecuniary interest councillor
Barrett spoke to me just before the
meeting has been properly cleared no
problem with councillor Barrett voting
and speaking as normal in this meeting
thank you very much there's no others
okay we'll move on item three is to
confirming the minutes
the meetin that was held on the 17th of
April and those members that were
present hopefully have gone through them
we'll take them page one I know the
number for page two if there's any
problems please stop me page 3 page 4
page photos that's the last page driver
proposed by Chancellor Osborne seconded
by Councillor Parker all those in favor
please show that's carried by all those
that were present thank you right item 4
to receive notifications of any
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition speed none received
you thank you very much item values site
inspections is there any site
inspections being called inspections the
officers sat across their will and will
come and present those particular items
perfect thank you so we'll do that now
then and we liked the first one come
forward to a microphone
this is technology we're all getting
used to
thank you Jeff good morning members
ladies and gentlemen I'm here to present
a formal Cyprus request from councillor
McCraw the councillor for ransom as you
will see shortly there is a significant
amount of sorry apologies Vincent Pierce
principal planning officer within the
development management service they'll
say I'm here to present this formal
request from Council McCraw currently
Brent firm is experiencing a lot of
development pressure and we have a
number of large and significant
applications coming up shortly in
Council of micro felt it right to try
and secure a visit by all members of the
committee for a good look round Branson
because the number of applications are
scattered around the whole whole village
so the first case in question is
Brooklyn's Road it'll be a reserved
matters application my own planning
position having already been granted
this is for some 288 dwellings Absalom
across fills that because it's a
complicated site it's it's on a
significant slope adjoins an existing
residential estate it has caused
significant interest within the village
obviously we do now have some new
counselors on the committee who wouldn't
have been available at the time of the
outline any permission councillor McCoy
feels it would be helpful for those
members to see that the siting context
and he also wants to be sure that this
public debate around the extent to which
the reserved matters accord with the
outline Planning Commission so in a
nutshell we have Brent firm alongside
the River Stour the area aged blue is
the application site you'll see to the
south of that is a large
largely now vacant industrial area some
significant landscape we have the IOM be
to the east area of outstanding natural
beauty the site itself is currently wild
to the right is a magnificent historic
decoy pond that will form part of the
proposal in terms of public open space
the key feature here is however the
estate at the top of the slide is on
land that's much higher than the land to
the south where the factory is is a
significant slope and trying to get the
development to fit nicely onto that
geography has proved challenging but we
think there's a good scheme to present
you on the 19th so it's coming up very
shortly so we're you minded to do a site
visit we haven't got much time to fit it
in the layout but that'll obviously be
shown to you in a lot more detail and
you can see the area on the right with
the decoy pond so there's a significant
amount of public open space involved in
this proposal that's the application
site residential to the north Azure say
industrial to the south
Brent firm is one of our key
regeneration areas so there are all
sorts of policy issues we would need to
explore but I think it is important for
members to see the whole site in context
there's a quick shot to show some of the
terrain we have the high land there a
number of valleys obviously there are
all sorts of tributaries running into
the store and the decoy pond is that
area in magnificent tranquil area and
again close view of the estate second
site that councillor macro would like
you to visit is Brenton place Church
Lane we are currently engaged in
considerable dialogue with the the
applicants we're hoping to bring this to
you in the near future as I say
discussion is ongoing and we're hoping
to see a scheme amended
in the near future okay at the moment
this is another interesting site very
heavily wooded with a significant
building in the middle and this is a an
application to try and scatter a number
of detached houses within the woodland
setting potentially an exciting scheme
but obviously within the context of
Brendan has considerable discussion
because I think I need to declare
another conflict of interest I think
this was coming forward I think you
simply know the owner counselor and that
that's a non-pecuniary interest which
can be recorded and declared and no
problem with continuing okay that's
noted thank you thank you these are the
four key areas that councilor macro
would like you to take in where you
minded to do a site visit I have my
colleague Jack who wishes to talk about
the 1/3 of applications light if we can
just bring Jack to the yeah Jeff I'll
disappear thank you very much
good morning members Jack Wilkinson
principal planning officer as Vince is
alluded to there's a sight towards the
north that Council of McCraw would like
us to conduct a site visit for its as
depicted by the yellow dot and it's to
the south of slough road it's 465 units
complete with affordable housing
landscaping access and various other
features which are as I say ongoing in
terms of discussion it is an outline
application with access as depicted by
the yellow outline to the north
Vince has already mentioned the land
tends to slope and the gradient falls
down towards the southern portion of
bran --them so we are in quite an
elevated patch as shown by the red line
outline agricultural land at present it
presents as a natural infill towards the
northern portion to the West is open
countryside and hopefully will if
members are inclined to visit on site
you will see the open nature there is a
link towards the south of the site
through to slough Road and then you've
got the access along the north of a
residential to the eastern side this is
an indicative layout as you can see the
units as proposed with open space and
landscaping
I'll hand you over to rob thank you
thank you thank you very much well
members I think we'll take these three
unblocked councillor Parker are you
proposing it thank you
do I have a seconder councillor Busby
you wish to comment well I think with
the cumulative effect of all these
applications I think it's important that
we do get to see the whole area and to
me it's a good opportunity we ought to
be doing more of this where we know that
there's going to be a number of
applications in a place go and see the
whole place rather than just the one
side yes you have often remarked on that
sort of approach so I'm pleased just
seconded it right members all those in
favor the site inspection please show us
unanimous thank you very much thank you
jack would you like to return we'll go
on to the next one we have another site
inspection request
we're just getting the who work on
blowing so that we can point it out to
members so just bear with us
Elizabeth Flood principal filing officer
this application is the land west of low
street Clemson and it's an application
for 101 dwellings and 35 retirement
living apartments it's been called for
Cypress if I counselor plum and there's
also some responsible counsel at the
Holts I don't know if you so chose a
comments from Council hall with regards
to the application unfortunately
couldn't be here today to get those
cross so he just asked a quick note for
these two pots
possums committee to Kate take into
consideration when making a site visit
he has asked please good members walk
foot past 41 and to point out the bus
stop
four hundred and three hundred and fifty
meters away to the proposed site please
view the inadequate and poor access to
the site on abandoned slope adjacent to
the certain on our sign is my opinion as
some someone that has lived in a village
for 54 years it's not suitable no
footpath from the site access into the
village low Street to church gate and
the visual impact of topography of the
site the heritage assets and the
landscape associated with the grade 1
listed church in the conservation area
and the special glass cave area
councillor pol has asked me to read that
out to the committee and they will also
be shared if and pointed out on the site
visit if members did choose to go it's
been cool because it's a major
application within the village you can
see and it's got impacts on various
heritage assets so that's the red line
site
you can see it's not particularly clear
but the church is the Green Building
just to the south east of the site and
then monks Hall is the building in red
to the north east of the site you can
see that on the aerial photograph that's
the layout and then just quickly just so
you can see the site is just past here
on the left it says pictures from the
church and there are a couple of
footpaths
that go through the site that which so
the site is here on the right which
would be worth looking at if you were to
choose to go on a site with it
you can see this is from the site
looking back towards the church members
have heard that or canceller and plums
I'm not very much
okay do you wish to have a site
inspection right proposed by Chancellor
buzz been seconded by Councillor Parker
all those in favor please show absolute
Animus thank you very much so we will
have sizes pictures and they will be
done on Wednesday the 12th of June
good morning so I give all you men
members I'm mark burns planning officer
baby mid-south district council got a
planning application at survey of Austin
house down Juke Street interim there's
been a petition see for this has been
called to committee because it's been
deemed controversial locally and called
for a site visit
I counsel that Busby so this is the site
opposed source of reaction of to
dwellings solar panels improved access
which will be severe of Roslyn on Duke
Street this is the I say the brown line
indicates a bill to barrier boundaries
it will be outside of that and going
against the prevailing form or to fellow
in down to extreme this is navy or for
sites
yeah so this is the post layout as I say
to the there'll be some solar panels
which will be to the real fossil in
house in the middle of the site plot one
will be the larger dwelling to the south
and plot to be the dwelling to the north
these are post plans for the plot one
the door line to the south and this is a
proposed dwelling for prepared plot to
to the north this is the Associated
outbuilding and gouge for plot one to
the south and this is the gallery
outbuilding for plot to the north under
these other sections of the site so this
is now your skin schematically
Africanist missus support the
application I've got the edge on three
sides and it established boundary to the
west this is the tree survey
at least some photographs of the sights
this is Rosslyn House their function via
this is the southern part of the site is
0.64 hector's and total the whole site
this is the tour's boundary to the west
or the agricultural land beyond this is
a few on the left sides the neighboring
properties along the extreme and this is
the plot to the north more contained us
and the bottom right is sort of
indicative area where the solar panels
be placed to the V of Auslan house thank
you um well members have seen all the
photographs do do you wish to go on site
inspection are you happy that the
photographs can tell the story when it
comes back to planning committee
councillor Busby yes chair I mean I as I
requested this to come to committee for
sizes it probably want to explain why
because it looks relatively simple clear
to the others and that think that is the
issue
it might look with it simple but there
are issues concerning this planning
application there's been a large amount
of interest shall I say locally not all
necessarily down to the application the
site's it's a very big site for two
extra houses and there are single-story
and therefore a lot of the opposition
maybe not so great in terms of he's not
going to be able to see them from the
road etc well there's also a very
peculiar village boundary which you see
seems to go round the site after the
site rather than including the site and
again I think that's worth taking on
board and there's an interesting design
so I think it's worth seeing and as as I
was saying as part of the view we could
take in that road down in Hindle sure
because there's a lot of development on
and there's potentially going to be a
lot more and this is one of those issues
where your do you accept pure linear I
think that's both the debate in the
council-chamber better I think your
point is taken so it's that a proposal
was what you save do it thank you do I
have a second that cleanser today just
wish to comment or you're happy
I remembered you've heard the views all
those in favor of a site inspection
please show that's carry only one
against thank you thank you
right I think that is now all those out
inspections a lot of site this is their
if members are happy
I will obviously put the most pressing
ones on the agenda first for if for
members to visit because some of them
might not come to committee straight
away in the next two weeks if members
are happy for me to go away and sort out
the date with regards to that and sent
around them once we have confirmed when
they will be going to committee yes
there will be one next Wednesday okay
yes that's the intention to try and do
them all yeah so it'll be a 9:30 start
right we're now remembers moved to item
number six which is plan applications
for determination today you've all got
your papers on page seven
and the case officer in this case is
Alex Scott over to you to take us
through it
thank you okay Thank You chairman ladies
and gentlemen my name is Alex Scott
presenting officer on principle planning
officer for baby district council and
the application today is sites at old
Buckingham Hall school breton and park
in breton um yeah application seeks full
planning permission for the erection of
seven new dwellings following the
demolition of two existing bungalows on
the site therefore we have a net gain of
five additional dwellings the
application is supported by a legal
agreement in the interest of securing
funds resulting from the Scott sale of
the dwellings to be used in the repair
and upkeep of existing school buildings
old Buckingham Hall which is great to
style listed so one of our most
important buildings the current proposal
as a result of pre-application advice
and negotiation undertaken by your
planning and heritage officers dating
back to November 2017 as stated in the
papers a panel of members visited the
site in January 2019 so here we have a
location of the site within the district
you can just see the the red sorry I
don't have a cursor here didn't expect
that but yeah they tell their laser
pointer go right just in this location
thank you Robert
this is a an aerial photograph of the of
the general area and Breton and park
itself
okay sorry this one Breton and park in
this location the village of Breton emit
self-centered around here where the
churches and linear pattern along Barry
Road and the street thought Maru the
neighboring village off in this location
and this is zooming in on Breton and
park itself here we have the skill
buildings and the access driveway to
that two gate lodges here which are
great - listed there's another great see
list of building on the opposite side of
the road at pound farm and existing
dwelling rocks at the site which is not
listed and the general site is in this
location I was even a bit more on the
next slide so the site relates to to
existing bungalows here Cedar Lodge and
Cedar Lodge and Claremont house and we
also have a modern dwelling here at
Biggs Hill that was a replacement
dwelling granted in 2015 the existing
bungalows date back to the 1960s and
planning permission was granted
originally in 1962 so here we have a
constraints map of the area and the
green areas are three preservation order
belts trees protected by tree
preservation orders the purple area is
the extent of the village conservation
area the village settlement or built-up
area boundary terminates here site is in
this location and the the color
buildings indicate the list of buildings
you have
the greatest our old buckin all the
great solicitude gate houses and rating
listed pound farm on the opposite side
of the road this is a site plan largest
scale
zooming in to a more detailed scale and
if you can just make out the the dotted
lines that's the location of the
existing bungalows to be removed and all
dwellings say for plot seven would be
built on the existing garden area of the
two bungalows and you've got about a 20
meter intrusion into the Breton and park
itself as set out in the report this is
the proposed visibility displays for the
improved access to the resultant mate
Wellings that's been assessed and
approved by the local Highways Authority
at a separate County Council here we
have the front elevations of all the
buildings proposed so seven new
dwellings but for buildings plots two
and three and then again it plots four
five and six would be within the same
building these are the elevations have
plot one and the floor plans so we have
a four bedroom detached dwelling
proposed here plots two and three and
these will both be three-bedroom
dwellings that's four five and six
I don't if you can make that out that
they will actually be three-bedroom
dwellings a piece these three seven we
have a five bedroom dwelling proposed
detached yeah
these are roof plans of all four
buildings and the card Lodge is proposed
and there we have the elevations of the
cottages this is to plot two and three
and then it plots four and seven this is
a proposed street scene elevation
showing rich Heights rich high
comparisons and taking into account site
level changes along allenbury Road and
the main point of this is to show that
the ridge Heights would be no higher
than the existing neighboring dwelling
at a Dukes Hill onto some photographs
for you these are the listed gate houses
to the drive to old Buckland home and
here we have a street scene elevation
the existing access to existing
bungalows and digs Hill in this location
that will be improved by way of the
permission if you minded to de grant
this is the dwelling immediately
opposite the site
step cottage the listed building
opposite at pound farm
this is Dukes Hill the replacement
dwelling granted in 2015 the existing
bungalow to be removed at Cedar Lodge
and then again at Claremont House also
to be relieved
part of the proposal this is a view from
the park land to the rear the larger
dwelling here is the neighboring
dwelling at Dietz Hill you can make out
Cedar Lodge and just moving around to
the left from that photograph Cedar
Lodge again Clermont eyes actually
obscured by way of the existing tree
Bund on the site and again moving around
to the left slightly and moving in in a
probably make out the listed gate houses
and for reference plot seven would be in
approximately this location and I'm just
turning the camera around there and
looking back towards old Buckingham all
school buildings and an additional item
for you has submitted by the applicant
paragraph two point eleven of the report
should include the raking act and repair
of brickwork
between site face wall of the walled
garden as part of the list of
improvements and repairs to the building
into will have to secure that by way of
the legal agreement as well right well
that concludes the officer presentation
as per the report our recommendation to
you is for approval thank each other
thank you very much right members we now
have members of the public wishing to
speak parish council pull window if
you'd like to come forward so you have
three minutes in which to address the
committee perhaps should remain seated
or standing and I'll serve as any
questions from members of the committee
to you afterwards thank you
thank you good morning ladies and
gentlemen my name is Paul bundle
chairman of Breton parish councils
planning subcommittee Breton the Parish
Council are the great majority of
residents subject to this proposal
not because we object to residential
development per se we welcome and
support appropriately scale developments
that sensitively integrate in the
existing settlement pattern and address
local needs
we have supported more than 12
residential development applications
including six new builds in the past 16
months our objections to this proposal
are that in the context of Breton size
and infrastructure it is
disproportionately large scale
relatively high value estate development
partly on a greenfield site and well
outside the village built-up area
boundary its unsympathetic to the
existing bone structure it replaced two
low-impact single-story properties on an
essential rural site with comparatively
large mass high value houses that would
sit obtrusively into and further erode
existing greenfield parkland in a
conservation area in March this year the
site was reduced to below the threshold
for affordable housing late in the
application process and without any
community involvement there's been
little if any meaningful engagement with
the community by the applicant to assess
the existing housing mix in the village
or any local housing gaps and needs it
is unclear to us how this proposal for
sustainable development policies Ratnam
has little infrastructure in those shops
or agility is no safe pedestrian access
to the site and limited public transport
and significant increased vehicle trips
would result we believe the applicant
overstates its status as a major local
employer its current nexus with the
village and connection with the local
community is similarly overstated in our
view we do not accept that proposal
gives any genuine public benefit to the
local community and we remain skeptical
of whether and if so how this can be
implemented a significant majority of
supporting commentators do not live in
the local area would be unaffected by
the development and are connected to the
applicant whereas a hundred percent of
the objecting commentators do live in
the local area they do remain supportive
of smaller more sympathetic developments
that integrate into the village built-up
area that strongly object to us a
housing state which we believe right
show their planning constraints on
established greenfield parkland outside
the village boundary and in the
conservation area we also remain unclear
how this proposal passes the enabling
development of tests listed building
fabric maintenance by the applicant
should in our view be seeming but
seemingly cannot be serviced from
surfaces generated by the applicants
business model and we remain concerned
that if approved this proposal will set
a precedent for further development by
the applicant or others outside of sorry
big upon inside the conservation area
and well outside the village core and in
conclusion we respectfully request that
the application is refused thank you
thank you very much sir members have you
any questions sorry if you can just
remain the one moment there might be
some questions to you members do you
have any questions for the last speaker
canceller Barrett I just have one
question it is unusual to see people
supporting an application in the numbers
that have been recorded what what leads
you to your conclusion that they're not
residents we have looked at the
commentators we have looked at where
they live we've looked at exactly their
relationship with a school and we have
taken informed advice that the majority
of them and we know this to be a fact
are not residents
thank you hence the part of your
question yes Thank You mr. Bendele given
that the principle of development
already exists at that location is the
parish councils objection to any
development at all or just this
development
I've sorry mr. birnley's they [ __ ]
just clarify in that position face given
the application that we've received it
is our objection to the application as
seen we have not seen any other
applications and I believe that I can't
speak on behalf the parish council but
we would be sympathetic to a reduced
application it's the size and scale that
we object to in the conservation area
thank you thank you any other questions
members no take thank you very much sir
you've turned to your seat we'll move on
we have the applicant agent David
Griffiths and it would getting coming
together or separately
whose are you David or April
have you been coming right you have
three minutes between you we can either
stop it halfway or how would you going
to do all the speaking and then the pair
of you may take questions okay thank you
very much
when you're ready good morning mr. chair
mr. chairman our members my name is
David Griffiths I'm the headmaster of
old Buckingham Hall school all
Buckingham Hall was founded in 1862 and
relocated to Bretton impart in 1956
since then we have taken great care of
the estate as its guardians the upkeep
of a listed building and the glorious
setting of Breton Park make great
demands on the school's financial
resources we are nevertheless proud to
be the trustees of this historic site
but we must now pan ahead to safeguard
both the heritage assets and the future
of the school the application before you
has been designed to strengthen the
position of the school via a sympathetic
scheme on previously developed land on
the periphery of the park the school is
a charity and does not seek to make a
profit
all services are therefore reinvested
however to give members an idea of the
scale of financial commitments faced by
the school this academic year alone we
have spent close to one hundred and
fifty thousand pounds on refurbishment
and maintenance and none of this has
been on new facilities
despite this level of investments we are
aware that the infrastructure of the
historic house and the landscape
requires continuing works to protect us
intrinsic and aesthetic qualities the
redevelopment of this small parcel of
land will enable us to undertake s106
works listed in the officer report works
which we enthusiastically want to
proceed with without this boost in
revenue these are not achievable our
maintenance costs will escalate and the
overall condition of the buildings and
park lands will deteriorate we must be
pragmatic that to maintain the heritage
of the site compromises must be found
otherwise it is not sustainable or
prudent stewardship as a
long-established local business we are a
significant employer with a rural
setting utilising a local workforce and
the local supply chain we would
respectfully ask members to support the
school and the professional
recommendations of your planning and
heritage officers by focusing on the
long-term and widespread benefits that
can be derived from enabling develop
to secure the long-term future of
Buckingham Hall moreover the proposed
scheme will financially underpin a
landscape strategy for the parklands
which will maintain and enhance this
historic setting as a school we have a
national reputation for excellence
however schools do not stand still and
to maintain our attractions the best
teachers and parents of respects of
pupils we need to upgrade our facilities
some of which are inadequate with no
endowments or central funding we need to
raise revenues in other ways this scheme
will allow us to begin a development
phase at the school that will include
covering the swimming pool building new
staff accommodation and ultimately
building a sports hall these facilities
will provide a community assets and the
governors of myself are committed to
ensuring our facilities can be used and
enjoyed by the local community as much
as possible I would like you to be under
no illusion that this development is
anything but vital for the future
sustainability of the heritage of value
at Bretton and park and its continuation
as a nationally respected school we
believe that the application before you
delivers this which can only be a good
thing for the park for bresenham's and
for beta thank you for your
consideration thank you our members have
got questions I've got one you said that
um
the facilities of this this D family
would help pay for in the long run they
could become available to the local
people in the area is that correct that
is correct we have a number of
facilities which are or have in the past
been used by the local community for
example we have the Breton own Cricket
Club plays as at the school and have
done for over a hundred years we have
the swimming pool which they uncovered
and is used by local swimming groups
whenever available we would like to make
massive 8 to 12 months facility so
that's a part of it
thank you I think that's answered my
question members do you have any
questions a cleanser the Jemison have
you explored other ways of increasing
your funding the school is very much
like a farming community needs to
diversify to raise income so we have
increased our letting income through the
course of this year for example
throughout the entire summer holidays
this year
we have lets in from to other schools
groups which is generating income flores
we're also looking at diversify and
other types of income as well whether
that be potentially in the future as a
wedding venue but those things are still
under consideration however the level of
investment of those areas bringing
bringing in is insignificant in
comparison to the potential sale of this
land is planning thank you
any other questions councillor Busby
it's an obvious attraction and a simple
way of gaining money to solve your
problems but will we see you here in
another four years asking for another
chunk of land for urgent money to keep
this place going I'm not sure whether
that's really a fair question it's when
we have to do Alice you know very well
care supposedly what's in front of us he
has mentioned that there's possibilities
that they could be improvements but
happy to answer the question since the
finances at the school are very
financially run we have made a surface
over recent years and we're projecting
to the future to make your continuing
service as well however this is a boost
that that we need in terms of intrinsic
and important works at the site there is
no future planning at all Thank You
Chancellor Busby one of the objections
from the parish council was the size and
scale if we could find something that
was more modest in the size and scale
would you just don't be prepared to put
that forward as an alternative or are
you waited to this particular
application I think if we're in success
in this application then the governing
body and myself and have to discuss a
future way forward so it's not something
that I could comment on at the moment
but there is every potential that it
could be Thank You Chancellor Barrett
I think the person from the parish
council so they disputed the number of
employees at the school and I think it
states that is about hundred can you
provide an update on that we have
approximately 95 employees at school and
we have done some work with Oxford
Economics Auris academics and IPS which
is our overseeing body in the last year
the the employees that we have are
largely based in the baby district we
think that we employ over six or seven
people through the supply chain both
directly and indirectly and we also
estimate that we we contribute about
naught point to 9% of GDP for the county
as well so we we do not have over 100
employees but we bounced around with 90s
95 mark thank you
any other questions members canceller
Davis and you would have seen the
objections from historic England and how
would you counsel their their argument
about the disruption and the harm that
they will cause to the local character
and also as part of the policy we need
to demonstrate how you would enhance or
make a distinctive positive positive
contribution to the whole of Britain of
not just the school how would you do
that there's a tech distance is our
agent first for this can served as I
will know that question to be asked
because he's a private obviously got an
answer but the heritage officer will be
speaking later to us soon
I'd like you to pick that pint up and do
over in your presentation thank you yeah
yes I know this a simpler okay
yes clearly the views of historic
England are very important essentially
it's a subjective judgement as to the
degree of harm or impact the development
has on the park we worked from day one
with heritage office of your heritage
officer and took stock of the situation
on site and and closed agreement with
him that the minimal that was minimal
visual impact of the development having
regard to the existing development on
the site
the
it isn't still largely a developed site
as it stands and that only a very small
part of the undeveloped parkland was
included in the scheme and having regard
to the existing structural landscape on
the edge of the site and the landscaping
proposals that we devised to mitigate
any visual intrusion on the park the
Heritage Officer from the very early
stage was convinced that the development
would not have any significant harm to
the setting of the listed buildings or
to the park land itself so except there
is a difference of view but the Heritage
Officer has looked at this at very close
quarters which I don't think historic
England have and the historic your
heritage officer has have stated in the
report endorsed the scheme right from
day one and based on the technical
information that we provided okay thank
you we do have the heritage officer in
the room so we can get them to comment
on this when we go in doubt and debate
okay any other questions No thank you
very much thank you the board member
Chancellor Lindsay was here earlier but
unfortunately couldn't stay that he has
handed a note to be read out so I'm
going to asked Rob here to read today
all the relevant parts please
Thank You chair so this is a development
outside the built-up boundary within a
conservation area in a village currently
classified as hinterland Gresham has a
church and a village hall that had
virtue and that's that's it as far as
amenities there is just one scheduled
bus to bury a week so this development
would be entirely car dependent the
development is of is on historic
parkland and I presume it is of historic
nature make sure of this parkland that
it is the reason it is included in the
conservation
area yes there were three bungalows
built there in the 60s for school staff
I doubt whether such applications would
have been one would have won approval
today they did harm the historic
parkland and historic meaning of that
parkland this proposal will encroach
still further on historic parkland and
its impact will be far greater than the
two modest bungalows that they will
replace the school has removed plot
eight from the original plan but plot
seven still is still an encroachment
outside the curtilage of the bungalows
further into the historic parkland
increasing the harm that was done in the
60s at the moment it is still possible
to walk up to those bungalows as I have
done earlier this year while
door-knocking
and feel that they are part of Britain
and Park and historic landscape they are
relatively unobtrusive and hidden in
what feels like a mini woodland on the
edge of the big park the new proposals
will inevitably be not as well hidden
given that their two-story and there
will be seven houses rather than two
they will require greater clear space
more driveways parking spaces car ports
and associated paraphernalia of a car
dependent estate because of all this the
only policy on which the development of
life of building the five extra houses
rather than it's just two replacements
is the exception of one of enabling
development this is what English
heritage say about the enabling
development enabling development is
normally a last resort as it is enough
inefficient means of providing funding
as it is akin to a type of public
funding proposal should be subject to
similar levels of scrutiny the tests
they recommend is that enabling
development should only be allowed if
your historic house is falling down to
such an extent that even after you've
paid for repairs the buildings new
market value does not recover the cost
of repairs the school has provided no
evidence of buildings value no costs of
the repairs needed to the fabric
initially it seems the school said the
money was needed to put a roof over the
swimming pool and refurbish the squash
court later after it seems life to him
after it seems planners pointed out that
the
portraits of enabling development being
seen to protect historic building they
came up with a list of repairs to the
actual historic fabric to me they amount
to not much more than ongoing
maintenance repointing of brickwork some
mending of the flashing on the roof and
so on old vacuum hall is a private
business it relies on the prestige of
its historic landscape and buildings to
attract his clients and it ought to be
able to fund the upkeep of these
buildings for the fees it charges its
clients it should not be allowed to harm
one of one part or suffix Heritage and
historic landscape and to fund ongoing
repairs to another part this is cutting
off the cutting off its nose to spite
his face once we give way on this
principle there is no end to it the next
time repair work is needed to old block
in Rockingham Hall we can expect another
application to take another piece of the
historic parkland landscape therefore I
urge you to refuse this application
unconvincing just to add that as you
mentioned check house and Lindzi was
here earlier but did have to leave and
we would have put that in the table
papers if he had said that anyway to if
there was any concern regarding that
statement thank you Jeff thank you were
known who asked questions of the ward
member but as it's not so it's very
difficult but if there's any comments
you wish to pick up from that then we
can do that in the general debate and
perhaps the officers can respond to that
in due course is there anything that you
would respond to in what you've just
heard right members that's all the
public speakers done so we're going to
debate and councillor Dave as you have
indicated to us to speak yes it's just a
bit of clarification for me apologies I
probably should know the answer already
but can you give me a bit
about enabling development in terms of
what our policies are what the national
policy question briefly I mean to be
honest my knowledge of it will probably
be less than that of our own heritage
officer who's here but effectively we
don't have yes we don't have a
particular policy that covers enabling
development but historic England does
set out what it considers to be and I
think the test is probably quite a high
bar to meet and in the circumstances
here I think it's probably acknowledged
that that test isn't met nevertheless I
think officers do recognize that you
know the capital receipts involved in
the disposal of the land to go to
development or the sale of the
development will be divested into the
support of that listed building and that
of itself is a compelling public benefit
that warrants you waiting in the
planning their planning a balance thank
you I'm good ask the Heritage a for so
if you'd like to carry ons on that point
thank you
Thank You chair freeze enabling
development as used by historic England
is specifically is very specific and
quite discreetly framed and since he
starting when changed their requirements
for enabling development and and produce
an enormous tone on the subject probably
about ten years ago now I my experience
is that no one involves himself with it
because it's so complex and so from the
very start of this case I made it clear
to the applicants and to the planners
and various people I was concerned not
to call it enabling development because
it would not meet district tests that
English heritage well now historic
England set out so it is development
that helps to facilitate works to the
school but it is not enabling in the
strict sense of the the phrases used by
historic England thank you very much for
that and just to point out that wasn't
me speaking there that was the Heritage
Officer councillor Davis a little bit
more help please how much weight do we
give this because obviously can
Lyndsey's made quite a point of it so
how much the weight the way as a
committee you use your choices the
decision takers here
I mean clearly heritage is one of those
particular matters and considerations
that is of great importance and you know
obviously if there's harm to a heritage
asset that warrants are considerable
weighting and importance in the balance
the corollary of course is that if
there's something there that's going to
support the long-term you know vitality
of that building and maintain its
significance or improve it or better
enhance it then that to warrant you know
a particular and important waiting and
the balance to and officers consider
here that where that develop will go to
that cause and can be secured by legal
agreements that's quite an important
consideration that warrants as I say
Gigi waiting in the balance
notwithstanding that across the rest of
the issues involved the tensions with
individual policies that are noted are
not particularly significant when
looking at the balance as a whole lot of
penciler jan i was born
Thank You mr. chairman i have three
questions would you like me to take them
on bulk or separately one at a time
right my first one is that although I
appreciate that the criteria isn't met
to provide affordable housing in
required to the site of the size the
size of the site sorry and that it's
under 10 units but I'd like to know if
it would it's disappointing to see that
there's not an element of at least one
unit of affordable housing well as per
the the current MPP F to provide
affordable housing it needs to be
considered to be major development and
that would be one of two things as per
my understanding the site would need to
be over half a hectare in in scale
and over 10th well ins
as this proposal is it's for less than
that it's a net increase of five
dwellings only and the site is and and
point five of a hectare our hands are
really tied
we can't insist on that thank you your
second question disappointing and also
on page 12 on the parish councils
comments it's gots we do not consider
proposal with meet proven local need and
consider no analysis has been carried
out in this respect have we got evidence
of an analysis being carried out on the
need no no analysis on the need that
wasn't part of the the supporting
information with the proposal of their
requirements if if Stephen could well I
think we you know we do have a policy
that requires what I think what is being
put forward to me you know identified
needs in the district obviously in the
absence of any evidence that's difficult
to pin down whether it satisfies it or
not I mean what is the what is the mix
being proposed breakdown on the mix you
have one detached five bedroom property
you have one detach four bedroom
property and then you have three bedroom
properties one pair of semi-detached and
terraces three so I think you know
exercising your judgment councillor
Osborne I think you know there is a mix
there and certainly there is a number of
larger properties but equally there is a
predominant number of smaller units to
cancel I was born deferred question
I have there again obviously it's
disappointing to see that there's no
element of two bedroom two properties
which I I would understand there would
be a need in a village of this size but
however yeah just this is just for
clarification on your report you've got
on bullet point two point five you've
got plot one is proposed to be a
four-bedroom dwelling and then on two
point eight you've got what one is
proposed to be a five bedroom dwelling I
assume from your presentation that it's
five some page 19 anyway the first one
yes you have apologies for that I can
just confirm plot one would be a four
bedroom dwelling as per the plans
proposed plans for not five four or five
yes thank you
so there's no file used well it's four
there is a five dwelling that is a plot
seven block one is a four-bedroom below
my apologies for the confusion thank you
I think I've got next
councillor Busby yes Jeff be able look
at slide 22 please and then moving onto
for me the the key here is that actually
they're already properties on the site
so it's not open park land it's like a
redevelopment of an existing site this
is what's proposed but then if you move
onto slide 31
this is the existing and then it's got
32 you can see that the existing
bungalows are hardly visible on that
side so they don't have a a negative
impact on the parkland in my view but if
you imagine those four buildings two
stories they would appear about the same
kind of height of the tops of those
trees so they would have an impact on
the parkland and policy see no.6 says
that development affecting the setting
of a listed building is justified in
terms of causing the minimum possible
impact to the heritage asset so to me a
simple way around this is that we should
have bungalows bungalows on this site
rather than two-story buildings I
wouldn't object to their being 2 3 4 5
whatever can produce the maximum return
for you guys for the benefit of the
school I think it is important that we
do look at this as providing funds to
keep our heritage assets a valuable
heritage asset in in good shape it's
just how we go about it if it was
bungalows I'd probably be in favor if
it's two-story I think we're doing more
harm than good thank you but that's not
the proposal that's before us
unfortunately very well cancel a Norman
Thank You chairman my apologies if this
is in the report but I remember from the
from the slides that was shown part of
the development area was covering a bit
where there is a there a trees protected
by a tree tree preservation order of
just wondering in the proposal are the
tree is going to be affected in any way
that are they going to be removed or
brewed or chopped down in any way just
wondering
so the trees protected by tree
preservation orders are highlighted in
green it's mostly in the belt along
Murray Road and there are a few sporadic
ones within the parkland none would be
removed as part of the proposal there
would be a few trees removed the
existing band behind Clermont house it's
been an arbor or a cultural report
submitted in support of the application
this has been assessed by the council's
tree officer and he's raised no
objections subject to the replacement
landscape planting which we can secure
by way of conditions so it's not
proposed to remove any treatment
spectral trees and in the conditions
there's the tree protection measures
that are noted yes okay any other
questions of debate actually penciler
Parker and I come to councilor Davis
Thank You Chet just a point of
clarification if Alex could please
paragraph 1.3 page 18 the application
site lies outside of the built-up area
boundary etc etc is considered to lie
within the settlement pattern of the
village amongst and adjacent to existing
dwellings that seems to contradict para
3.9 on 21 that says the site is located
to the south east of random and as such
the proposal does not demonstrate a
close functional relationship so could I
just have some clarification on that yes
the closed functional relationship to
the to the built up area boundary is
referred to in in 3.9 and in terms of
engaging apartment policy CS 11 my yeah
my general assessment is it's within the
existing settlement
to to that area of a berry road that
that area of the Parrish if you will but
the village is defined by the existing
built-up area boundary that's okay okay
cancel the Davis yeah that partly
answered one of the questions I have but
I have concerns in the report in your
conclusion and the balance of both cs2
cs3 CSL Evan and cs50 and and I think
even in your report you accept that it's
virtually contrary to CS 15 so I'm
trying to work out the balance because
we've we've already heard that there
isn't going to be no benefit to the
local need no because there is none but
we have no assessment the parish has
made it very clear that they see no
benefit locally at all it's partly
outside of the built-up area boundary is
there is some building on existing part
land not just the thing so I'm just
curious as to how you see that the
benefits outweigh the harm answer that
the the only benefits that were outlined
was to the locals on the improvements
that possibly could come to the school
but not in the local house indeed yes in
terms of the planning balance I mean
it's it's three pronged in terms of the
MPP F environmental social and economic
I mean there would be a certain degree
of environmental harm in terms of the
scale of the buildings and where they
but it's felt that that is offset in
terms of the the monies which would be
secured to the upkeep of the historic
buildings and there's a an amount of
social benefit in terms of the supply of
additional housing in terms of our
housing housing thicket as well so
that's that's as I've tried to sum up in
my report just one more clarification
and it's not this so for the office it
might be of someone else but how much
public access is there to this public
access to this area I don't believe that
sort of the question that the officers
can answer albeit obviously
acknowledging the the comments that the
applicant made in respect of the
facilities that were available to
members of the public so there must be
some access for that to happen mustn't
there yeah
members I could with your permission
asked the applicant if he can answer
that Pacific point only remembers do you
wish me to put that to the applicant
that's the general fear then yeah okay
could you just answer that if it just
come forward yeah you need to come to
moat because I've always it's not picked
up for the record you heard the question
you don't want it really phrased a no I
do thank you and there is significant
public access there is a footpath that
runs through the park which is used
widely by the village and people
visiting the area in fact that footpath
and the tracks have been highlighted
recently by the parish council to
encourage their use of new signage I
think has been put up I might be
incorrect I think that's the case every
year we host a fireworks night which the
entire village is welcome to and that's
happened for many years
the Breton Creek that was played there
for over 100 years the swimming pool is
used whenever the weather has clamors
enough for swimming and in the past the
squash courts have been used by public
as well and would be again in the future
with renovation sorry at the bargman and
let's say there is a public footpath
that runs straight through the park
lands so there is public access thank
you
I think that's answered Atlantic believe
you're happy with that response of it
yep thank you
any other comments members can still
Parker Thank You chair and I'm not
really sure at least one necessarily the
officers can answer but I'm just curious
to know throughout the report that much
is made of the impact upon and quite
rightly that elicited heritage asset
within the grounds itself but there
doesn't appear to be any mention of the
listed asset that is immediately
opposite the the development itself I'm
just wondering if the officer has any
comment about that I think we ought to
ask the Heritage Officer to answer that
if that's okay yep okay thank you
no no reference main pound farm you mean
I think because morphologically Breton
amis fairly strung out and there are
little there are little knots of
development and and individual buildings
and spaces and we felt that by building
opposite and utilizing the existing belt
of trees that are there and it's a
fairly deep cups of trees the the inter
visibility would be good contained
they'll be very limited into visibility
the setting of the farmhouse itself
wouldn't really be upset it would be
affected there would be an impact but
that impact doesn't equate to harm
because there is if there is a change to
the view from the house towards that
sort of green and vice first I'm looking
at away there'll be a change but we
didn't think that that change amounted
to any harm because of the the
arrangement of buildings in that
settlement already so so while the
building might sit in I suppose relative
isolation and and the setting does
contribute to that that aspects of the
setting which contributes wouldn't be
detrimental affected by being altered
thank you thank you another question
yeah if I can respond to that then mr.
chairman I wonder if it's possible to to
put the graphic back on the screen that
show yeah okay that one will do and so
what we're being asked to consider is
the give weight to its the effect of the
harm on the asset that is all the way
down there but not silence they we
discount but we're not being asked to
consider to give weight to the asset
that is immediately adjacent to and that
I've that's that's that's problematic
for me I have to say but that's just a
little bit of comment yeah can you help
on that point and perhaps help him out
there sorry yes thank you the setting of
the various assets is different and the
setting of the whole includes all the
for the land around it all the parkland
and probably beyond because the meaning
of the whole when it was built was to be
an impressive structure in the landscape
and only it created a formal landscape
in which people could appreciate that
building the farmhouse conversely is a
building and build for functional
purposes or BIA this is a very
high-status farmhouse built for
functional purposes and the setting
would be different it doesn't mean it's
any great to any less but the setting
because of the meaning of the building
is different the the meaning of the hall
is is very high-status
look at us we've got a huge house and
we've got fantastic parkland we're very
fashionable 200 years prior to that the
house was built on the other side of the
road and it was a concern with status
but it's concerned with the functions of
the house and its outbuildings I suppose
much of many of which have gone and so
the settings of each are discreet and
it's very different in terms of their
magnitude as much as they arrange Minh
and I wouldn't want to define where the
settings of each are they certainly
overlap as well the settings we've
certainly overlap but the if we were to
simply
argue in terms of the area of the
setting of the farmhouse that would be
significantly limited less then I think
the setting of the hall thank you
hopefully that philosophy
any other comments councillor Barrett
[Music]
just wondered if you could address a
comment to use or question a little bit
about the fabric of the hall now and it
sounds like you have been in touch and
looked at the condition of the of course
heritage assets are incredibly
problematic for maintaining them in the
way that they deserve what is your
opinion of the conditions that have been
talked about in in the paper the the
improvements and maintenance how long do
you think that would allow a period of
grace before you're on the constant
round again for more improvements yes a
bit of a tricky one historic buildings
didn't require constant maintenance and
parkland and as the head teacher said
there is been there is a requirement to
maintain these things we do have two T's
under the Act to ensure that they don't
adhere and of course when a building is
used it wouldn't deteriorate we hope to
to an extent where the roof falls in or
something but things like boundary walls
do deteriorate on a regular basis and so
ongoing maintenance is required but I
wouldn't like to put a figure or a
period of time to to do a cycle of
maintenance but needless to say the the
cycle of maintenance I suppose for mr.
Billings is ongoing but I don't know
when and if the applicants might come
back and fall for further funding
thank you another question yeah
question I have are there any green
credentials that are being put forward
as in the house building plans no we
don't have any detailed smelly green
elements no simple answer really I would
think it would certainly be all the
latest technology and the up-to-date of
rules and regulations would have to
apply they wouldn't they would pick up
some of the brilliant yeah yeah so
building regs will pick up sir well
that's debate as Part L now it is quite
a hot certainly a higher standard than
it has been in the past which is
certainly a high benchmark than probably
it would have been when the core
strategy was being drafted yep any other
comments members
right hence Lopaka
well in the absence of no other comments
mr. Chairman I think we've kind of
getting to the year to the nub of it
then in that case so my thoughts on on
listening to all the comments all around
is that this this proposal is it's not
particularly controversial in in any way
for me personally it's not sufficiently
controversial to its warrant anything
other than supporting the application
the you know when we talk about
sustainable development as as the
officers mentioned we're looking at
economic social and environmental
aspects and from what I've heard I am
satisfied that this development actually
satisfies all three of those all three
of those prongs insofar as there is a
social objective there is a public
benefit mr. Griffith has already
explained that actually this is used by
members of the public or the site in
question is used by members of the
public and it sounds to me as though the
school is an intrinsic part of the
fabric the society locally so I think
that we we have a social benefit the
this development is not a speculative
development from what I'm reading and
from what I'm hearing the proceeds will
be reinvested to support a very
important existing heritage asset but to
support economic growth as well looking
after the existing employment that goes
on site and ensuring that future so I'm
satisfied that there is an economic
objective being met here and also as far
as environment is concerned this might
be a little more tenuous but it but
overriding above everything else the
principle of development is already
established there is already development
here so what is being proposed is is a
replacement of something that is that is
already there and it's it's purely
subjective but in my opinion the
application that's before us actually
provides or would provide an improve
government to what exists currently I
take on board what counsel Busby said
there about the Straits thing but
actually we're looking at it from
completely the opposite direction so I
think it was an unfair representation so
for me with all of those things combined
and given that we can only judge the
case before us on material fact and
planning policy I think actually we have
no other option but to support officer
recommendation to approve the
application before it was German and
that is a proposal thank you Thank You
councillor Agee and husband second yes
thank you glad to to second this
proposal once again there my thanks to
the planning officers who have been with
involved with this I think it was a good
presentation
it showed everything that was wanted I
concur completely with the councillor
Parker this is a situation where the
conditions have been put on there and if
they apply those conditions I feel that
you had the best judgment at all on this
application thank you thank you is there
any other comments councillor Davis yeah
well accepting what councillor Parker
says I think there is a lot of parkland
in addition to into the land that's
already been built on that that is in
the in the pollen application so there
will be a loss of parkland yeah I do
have concerns about the enabling
development and that really the only
beneficiaries it could even be
short-term is the school rather than the
whole community so I just wanted to
point those out and and and finally if
if it is granted I would like to ensure
that and that the suffering fire and
rescue suggestion about a hydrant nearer
the actual site is put in whether as a
condition or the planning
can you tell us again today page 16
however I'm not sure that they're
necessarily recommending that the hi
shouldn't be be moved or that a new high
would be provided I think what they're
doing is noting the distance they're
recommending that there is provision of
fire sprinkler sprinkler systems in the
buildings and that's certainly I think
it is commendable and I should imagine
it's probably covered by buildings
anyway buildings I think if members feel
it prudent we'll add it on anyway well
do you feel it's necessary if it's
already covered in the sprinkler system
and that which actually is very good
because certain did you get sprinkler
systems in these nowadays isn't that
easy I think it must have been looked at
very closely by the fire department
indeed my personal preference would be
not to its members choice and decision
whether they wanted to or not right I
think you've heard the two different
sort of comments on it does the proposer
and seconder wish to add this on or are
you happy with the provisions that are
already there
no it's canceled the park review and
proposed it in the second the officers
have said they think that it's covered
enough in the recommendation chair I'm
perfectly prepared to accept what the
officer is telling someone on just a
little bit you know I'm just a bit
confused about what we're talking about
I mean it seems to me what talking about
as a sprinkler system within the house
there's nothing to do with the with with
it is to do with you know a modern fire
system
I'm quite certain that as you quite
rightly said will be covered under
building race in any event thank you and
your that canceler Osborne you're you're
happy with that oh yes thank you miss
Jamie I'm quite happy with that if the
officers requires that then so the
proposal stands as a as it was the
officers recommendation s it is has been
proposed and seconded any other comments
Chancellor Busby well can I just point
you to page 23 I mean I mentioned it
before policy cnsas
its unambiguous it says that it has to
cause the minimum possible impact now we
know that there are potentially two
alternatives here one is or filters what
is to do nothing which doesn't benefit
anybody secondly is to produce some kind
of replacement type buildings ie
bungalows and thirdly is to put in
what's proposed now what property is
proposed is not the minimum it is a lot
worse than having single storey
buildings therefore we'd be going
against a specific one of our save
policies I'm not against development on
the site I'm against a development that
causes more harm than it needs to
rather than go into a discussion about
the states of sea no.6 its age and how
consistent it might be with national
policy I don't think that's a stone we
necessarily need to kick over because
actually what you've got in respect to
the Heritage comments and that officers
amido stack chily the proposal before
you is causing the minimum level of harm
it is effectively trifling in it in its
nature at you know what might be
considered a spectrum of harm and it is
considered to record with the
development policies this has already
been rehearsed earlier during the meet
and
gingka unless you've got any new pipes
more comments no everyone's finished
with those views right there members
it's been proposed by Council apart from
seconded by Councillor Osborne that we
accept the officers recommendation as on
your papers in front of you all those in
favor please show those against for that
is carried thank you very much members
[Music]
we've come to the end chair just just
just to say I mean it we've just always
interesting to know when we've had when
we pass these or make these approvals
have we got any indication of when you
know when we might expect development to
to commence
but that's actually quite a good point
and we approached to try and remember
members between us to ask the aptness
how long that with your consent
harold quickly is this likely to be
enacted
thank you upset so sooner rather than
later members I think and tear them was
right we're now at the end of the
meeting just to remind them we usually
asked at this point is there any members
who know that they weren't there to make
the site inspections now will next
Wednesday yet just ask a question here
about the site visits are we likely to
be all day on these site visits or
certainly be all morning we're hoping to
start early and I think we were hoping
to go to glimpse but first and then move
over to the others that we have never
done by lunchtime thank you so right so
you're being cluded then next Wednesday
I've got previous engagements but I know
Brandon's very okay yep and hence John
Osborne you're subbing for sua is
canceling Aires
if she we don't know what if you make
will send a copy to her and perhaps your
include I know that counts Osborne will
be substituting on the next committee
because councillor Osborne is not member
of a formal committee okay we can't do
that unless I'm formally notified that
councillor Osborne will be at the next
meeting as well but don't move Oh mr.
chairman and if that is the case where I
need to start up again
now attend the site visit that's very
helpful thank you
right members declare the meeting closed
at 11:04 yep